the food industry is under full-scale
assault the crisis is global more of us
are wanting to know the source of the
food we buy if you don't know what's in
your food get out of the business in the
last 50 years
food has turned into a commodity to be
treated like a stock or bond with money
to be had there always be fraud and the
marketplace this has consequences beyond
description what people don't realize is
farmers are fading you used to be able
to be this big happy family that stayed
home together I work together all the
time that's not the case anymore
we're aiding and abetting a massive act
of theft people should be concerned
about this get all the fish you want you
have no idea where it's coming from any
of it frozen once two three four times
all kinds of additives at your
supermarket butcher the parts from a
single chicken will run you more than
seven dollars to raise a per the grower
was paid thirty six cents the supply
cannot meet the demand consumers are
eating a product it's not having nearly
half of food allergy deaths are caused
by food from restaurants our bodies are
rejecting the food we eat
and even the experts don't really know
why it has to be someone that's willing
to keep the fight alive this is all
about making us big profits as possible
this will look in a half million dollars
working hard as any money now you also
have to work smart people start to
realize how wrong this is
[Music]
nobody's hands are clean you eat food
this is an issue you need to worry about
[Music]
you
[Music]
you